et la 20e édition du Mois Molière a été
lancée mais officiellement c'était ce
samedi 4 juin à Versailles alors parti
de la place d'Armes une charrette a
parcouru les rues de la ville comme vous
pouvez le voir à l'image elle a conduit
les comédiens de la compagnie
l'archicube vers la plage charot où ils
ont joué snagarel de Molière alors cette
balade rappelle symboliquement les
voyages en charrette de l'auteur de
comédie et de sa troupe à travers la
France une tradition renouvelée et voulu
par le maire de la commune François
deasier écoutezle il était au micro de
William L il y a 20 ans quand j'ai lancé
le mois c'était avec Francis Perin j'ai
demandé à Francis d'être sur une
charette comme comme Molière au fond il
Ava été extraordinaire et là pour 20e
anniversaire on s'est dit on va
reprendre des
charrettes une parade si vous voulez
pour ouvrir les balles voil ça ve pour
annoncer public que ça va commencer